so we've just done a video on feedback
and feed through when we had this board
layout helping to explain the difference
in the last video we had a Google Doc is
the kind of artifact a user interface
and a user times multiple people so
let's quickly connect that to Twitter
because we're going to talk about
Twitter and Facebook for Twitter the
artifact in the middle is a kind of
tweet this is something that the people
produce and then people look at it
through different user interfaces their
phone or browse or whatever to interact
with it and in facebook let's let's say
that the main artifact in Facebook is a
social media post which might be a video
or a picture or a message so let's get
this out the way now without losing all
the air deliciousness so now we're going
to talk a bit about an example study we
did was a few years ago now as a
collaboration between me and a friend in
Germany and his student who came to
visit
we worked here for a while and we were
interested in why people use the
favorite button as it was at the time on
Twitter there's a little hot button
which I think they call the like button
but it used to be a star and it was a
favorite button so we did a pretty large
survey we had six hundred six people on
for that survey and there were multiple
aspects to that survey but the key
detail for this discussion is that we
asked people to in general say why do
favorite a tweet or like a tweet
favorite a tweet and then we said so
thank you for that that example can you
show us the last one your favorite and
explain why you favorite that one and
the reason we do both those things is
because if you get people to talk
hypothetically about situations you end
up with pathetic data hypothetically and
then if you ask people to talk about an
actual example something they've done
you get more factual data as why tend to
say so had these examples of why people
had favorited all these tweets lots of
examples and this was questioning and
then we coded up all the examples and
produced a taxonomy of 25 reasons which
got picked up by BuzzFeed and they call
it why we favorite tweets according to
science there are quite a few comments
back was saying it's not exactly science
but it's a survey study we did and it
was interesting and helped us to examine
the design of a protect
feature one aspect and how it does feed
through it feedback and everything like
that in that regard we can talk about
why did they change it to a heart it was
I think it was early to know I was it at
some point they changed it to heart I
did have it locked up on my computer
somewhere but at the time they argued
the differs because it was a more
universally recognized icon for showing
that you like things and actually we can
see that the function of a bookmark star
which is where we see the star most
commonly used is mostly assigned to just
kind of collecting things or you know it
being a kind of thing you want to come
back to which was only one portion of
all the reasons we saw people using the
favorite button
whereas a heart slash like represents
the majority of the cases we were we
were talking about and they liked it or
they found it useful information or
emotionally stimulating or were think
worth they kind of liked to it or to say
that they approved of it and things like
that this is more aligned with nonverbal
communications to say that something was
good or approved or that you liked it
essentially and so the icon matched more
the multiple use cases this the next
question you could ask then as well if
we have so many use cases for this like
button or this favorite button whatever
it is at that point should it be more
than one button and here we're talking
about the complexity of the user
interface
versus the likelihood that people want
to say different things versus the
amount of space you have to let them do
those things you know forcing the user
to think until it becomes intuitive what
they're saying by clicking on this
button
so if you add options you add choice and
therefore you add think and then you add
barriers to them doing it so you want to
make sure the technologies design so
it's super easy to do those things if
you want them to do it if you make it
possible to do it but super complex to
do it then you're increasing the barrier
to actually doing it and the motivation
you lose the motivation to do it and
people don't do it so they could for
example have a kind of save button next
to tweets we should fulfill the separate
functionality of keeping things fused
for later and have those go into a
certain space where you find those
because and then have a separate one
which is just you communicating you
don't want to see that to it again
necessarily but you said you liked it
I was allowed you to do that so yeah if
you had these two separate functions
that might make it clearer why you have
the buttons and use them separately and
to give you more power and more
functionality without adding too much
but if you start having 25 different
buttons in there you're challenging the
tolerance that people have for using
your software
there's user interface designers or
software builders it's our choice is our
decision then to try and support the
things that people are trying to do with
your software as best as possible and a
lot of user interface design is trying
to first establish all of those ways
that people might use software and then
monitoring how people use your software
then helps you to refine and improve
things over time which is why we see
social networks changing on this quite
regular basis to allow people to do the
things they are trying to do and then a
finding hacks to do so you could say
that the way they're using the favorite
button was kind of a hack its main
functionality especially with the
competition's this is people reusing the
function for something else and maybe
that's why we know we start to see
specific poles being built into Twitter
because now you can actually give people
options and have them click on it and
then show you the results because it's
giving people the functionality that
they want to do with their community and
without them having to reuse and confuse
the use of a particular function they've
already built in you just have your list
of favorite of tweets and now it's your
list of likes tweets and you still have
access to that but it's got in there all
the things you've sort of told someone
you liked or you you know buddy
communicated and you don't necessarily
want to keep there as long-term oh no no
I can imagine this as a way from this
particular one feature that that
software might still a bowl over time
but that one feature is in lots of
different bits of software lots
different social networks so in
Instagram we see the same heart button
next everything and what the way they
show you the way they feed through
information about what the people done
about your artifact tweet your Instagram
pictures is you see this kind of a an
icon which is a number of hearts and
then another one which is a number of
comments on it and so you kind of get a
metadata view as you hover over each
each picture that you've put out now
that's just
all sorts of collaborative things you
know YouTube has that how many comments
you've got having you like somebody
dislikes Facebook Instagram
so it's interesting mention YouTube
because YouTube's got a thumbs up and a
thumbs down and then you start to see
kind of people getting quite upset or
what does it mean that you've had you
know so many PUMS downs in the next
video we're gonna talk briefly about the
social phenomena that those different
functions create because there was also
this desire a lot of people want to have
a dislike button on Facebook and they're
always saying they you know we want to
have this want have this with it and
then never really existed and that's
because the button was really there to
approve of what was posted and so if you
get approval then that's good because
you put you personally how do you think
people like to see and then you get
account of whether people liked it but
there are obviously lots of examples
where people post things that they think
other people would like to see because
it's a bad situation they want other
people they think other people would
want to know that that's happens so yes
somebody spreading the news but then
then there's this quandary as to well
how do we how do we notify those people
that we've seen that without saying like
because we don't like you'd see lots of
examples people liking it and then
saying I pressed like because I want I
want you to know that yeah that I've
seen it and I I know that you're a loss
like that you know they want they want
to show approval non-verbally but
without yeah so so Facebook in early to
16 did have this full of range of
responses that they could use so that
you could express upset but without
directly saying that you think something
is bad like you think a post is a bad
post you could express it full of range
of emotions and what they were done is
work quite carefully on how easy it was
to do that because obviously you're
adding complexity to the process and I
guess a lot of people do just probably
still press like without engaging with
the more deeper ways of expressing their
emotion to it
I think there's possibly cultural
differences as well because I mean in
Britain we're not likely to throw some
tears at something necessarily just
because you know whereas I think they
sent in other cultures that they're
people are more direct sometimes but
that's maybe me being a bit stereotyping
those Brits yeah I think you're right in
terms of the difference between some
cultures but it's interesting to know
whether or not there's a difference in
use or a quantifiable difference in use
for the icons so yeah so it's
interesting to think why if they got
these extra features how do they design
it to make that easy people to use
without it being a cost barrier and the
way they did that is by having the
button there for you to press if you
want to but then if you hover and
interact you can be more expressive if
you wanted to be more expressive and
it's now easier there's technology is
better such this easier to do that and
so the barrier of doing it is less so
it's now easier to build it into a
social network without ruining use of it
this is the technology barriers being
reduced so the technology readiness
which was back from my first video and
to make the motivations of people wanted
to do it easier so it's a less of a
hurdle to jump over in all be imaging
see if we see these types of more
expressive communications nonverbal
communications come in to other
platforms as it becomes easier and so
what we're gonna do on the next video
starts to talk about why systems are
designed certain ways if you change how
to design what behaviors it encourages
or discourages and then how those
different bits of software relate back
to the theories we had originally and
see what behaviors they encourage on
social networks or social software
systems
so sometimes he floppies wood dies he
often would make backup copies let's try
this one sounds more hopeful and so
there was this game called Lander